[Música]
buenos días alegrías
y ese ánimo donde quedó buenos días
alegrías
hace unos meses estuve compartiendo un
espacio con comunidades mayas en el sur
de nuestra república mexicana y me
pareció una gran fortuna en la mía no de
tener ese privilegio de compartir este
espacio
me enseñaron muchas cosas y todo empezó
con un saludo no sé si ustedes saben
pero muchas de las comunidades de los
pueblos originarios saludan con un que
dice tu corazón y dice que dice tu
corazón va más allá de un como estas no
se va a la decencia de la persona y ese
que dice tu corazón a mí me hizo
reflexionar sé que todos tenemos
creencias muy distintas sobre el origen
de la vida así como las semillas no
algunos podemos pensar pues que nos creó
un un ser supremo y otros
hicieron la vida se hizo debajo de las
grandes capas de hielo otros pensarán
que también la vida se originó en estas
grandes capas de barro no donde
existieron estás esta creación
espontánea digamos de la evolución de
las moléculas o único organismos del
metabolismo que de repente el rn hace se
originó y la vida también surgió a
partir de eso hay en de cantidad de
teorías sobre el origen de la vida pero
bueno no lo sabremos no ya han pasado
miles de millones de años después de
todo esto hasta los extraterrestres nos
cayeron los reptilianos nos trajeron las
ventosas submarinas de donde también hay
este estos microorganismos que van
surgiendo y van creando la vida pues
bueno en cantidad de cosas lo que sí
quiero compartir y lo que creo que
debemos de reconocer independientemente
de lo que nosotros creamos como el
origen de la vida es que cada una de las
personas que aquí estamos presentes y
las que están en este mundo que
habitamos tienen características
y a partir de eso es que nosotros de
repente nos relacionamos algunos por la
ciudadanía de donde son donde nacieron
otros el nivel socioeconómico si vienen
de cierto sector o de otro y eso nos va
caracterizando y nos va dando digamos
valor en la sociedad desafortunadamente
nosotros hemos dispuesto ciertos valores
en las personas a partir de sus
características de nuestras
características si somos mujeres si
somos hombres si nuestra preferencia
sexual es una es otra nuestra
orientación o nuestro género cómo nos
identificamos el tipo de colectividad
donde estamos nos congregamos no también
el nivel educativo si tenemos una
educación si somos analfabetas y sabemos
leer escribir si tenemos primaria
terminada si llegamos a un doctorado
aunque debo decir que algunos tienen un
papel de doctorado sin nunca haberse si
nunca haber entrado una escuela no
entonces también es hay que reconocer
tampoco los papeles te dicen mucho de
las personas ni de su capacidad ni de su
nivel educativo
hay que estar muy atentos en esos
pequeños detalles en la ocupación que me
dicen ustedes cómo se relacionan con las
personas que hacen el aseo o el
mantenimiento de los edificios que
nosotros habitamos a veces no el
mantenimiento de nuestras ciudades obras
públicas por ejemplo no sé si se
relacionan igual con estas personas que
con un doctor
cirujano un director y un director de
alguna gran empresa algún presidente de
otra de un consejo directivo de otra
empresa o de una institución
la edad que me dicen cuando vienes con
una idea nueva y eres muy joven y te
dicen eres inexperto por eso no
empezamos a dar un tratamiento
específico a las personas a partir de
ciertas características en su mayoría
estas y desafortunadamente el
tratamiento que le damos a estas
personas también pone mucho en riesgo a
la manera en que nosotros podemos
relacionarnos en esta sociedad y cómo
podemos nosotros también llevar esta
sociedad adelante lo que sí vemos
siempre es la apariencia no lo que va
arriba lo que se expone lo que no
necesariamente se ve las raíces que yo
les acabo de compartir hace ratito
entonces que sucede nosotros tratamos al
individuo sin considerar lo anterior o a
partir de simplemente como lo ven o como
lo vemos no como nos vemos nos tratamos
desafortunadamente eso es cierto muchas
de las ocasiones y les atribuimos valor
a las personas a partir de todas estas
características que les acabo de
mencionar hacia ratito el reto para
todas las personas también es poder
nosotros relacionarnos y vincularnos de
una manera distinta teniendo presente lo
otro que les parece empezar
a ser considerados en la forma que
nosotros nos relacionamos tomar
encuentra estas raíces que estaba
mencionando hace ratito para poder
nosotros vincularnos con las personas de
una forma adecuada que les parece tener
paciencia a partir de esta consideración
todo un reto a veces no lo digo que
todos somos perfectos pero podemos
empezar a tener esto presente para
generar otro tipo de relaciones humanas
qué les parece esto de la empatía estar
en los zapatos del otro o de la otra es
difícil porque pocas veces podemos
entender podremos entender lo que siente
lo que ha vivido otra persona si no lo
hemos vivido igual no no es lo mismo
alguien que vive en el campo que alguien
que vive en la ciudad no es lo mismo
incluso la pobreza en el campo que la
pobreza en la ciudad creo yo que es más
ruin la pobreza en la ciudad porque si
no tienes forma de poder pagar o tienes
efectivo pues es difícil que pueda
sobrevivir si nadie te ayuda no en el
campo lo mejor tienes más suerte puedes
tener una semilla a ser muy paciente y
eventualmente eso te da un fruto o lo
que tienes ahí a la mano que la
naturaleza te da equidad reconocer que
como existen características distintas
diversas nosotros tendríamos también que
comportarnos de una manera distinta no
reconocer que las que las diferencias
son un área de oportunidad para hacernos
más fuertes como sociedad
la integridad conducirnos con integridad
creo que es difícil también para muchos
pero sabemos que este gran ejercicio
puede llevarnos a
un diálogo mucho más certero mucho más
asertivo con las personas queremos una
sociedad distinta tenemos que practicar
cada una de estas cosas son ejercicios
complejos la solidaridad sé que en algún
momento lo pusieron de moda no de
nuestros en nuestras instituciones
públicas pero va más allá de un discurso
político tiene que ser un discurso
humano tendríamos que ser más solidarios
tendríamos que reconocernos como humanos
qué les parece la equidad
y la verdad conducirnos con la verdad no
siempre nos permite
lleva relaciones hacia donde queremos
pero si nos va a facilitar poder
construir sociedades mucho más asertivas
las instituciones que necesitamos que
queremos que soñamos
y la humildad creo que es una cosa
compleja compleja porque eso también nos
tiene que llevar hacia un mismo nivel
reconocer que todos sentimos que todos
tenemos un corazón que todos tenemos
sentimientos y que desde nuestro origen
a la fecha todos hemos vivido
situaciones distintas y esas situaciones
desafortunadamente nos hacen
comportarnos y responder diferente a lo
que nos enfrentamos tendríamos que tener
eso presente para poder nosotros
trabajar ser una sociedad con mayor
unidad yo les muestro aquí palabras que
tendríamos o que enseñaría yo que
estuviéramos nosotros presentes en cada
decisión que tomamos en la forma en que
nos relacionamos porque creo que es lo
más complejo de poder llevar con
nosotros no tenemos esa responsabilidad
de conducirnos con honestidad con
nosotros mismos conocernos conocer las
capacidades que tenemos conocerlas las
características que poseemos y como eso
también nos hace ver y nos da un valor
ante la sociedad para hacerlo de una
manera más correcta hoy el respeto
después de todo está el respeto creo que
es algo que nos fortalecería en caso que
nosotros no podríamos no pudiéramos
ejercer cualquiera de las otras palabras
que yo les estoy mostrando porque porque
si no somos capaces de ser empáticos
pero si respetuosos eso puede llevarnos
a otro espacio a otras formas
a ser más justos con las personas
difícil verdad son palabras que hemos
escuchado parecen sencillas pero
poderlas practicar no es algo tan simple
pero bueno el compromiso eso eso es lo
que podemos llevarnos al menos de
practicar cualquiera de estas palabras
estos valores que nos dicen que son
importantes y si lo son si lo son porque
así nos gustaría que nos trataran así
nos gustaría que se conducirán con
nosotros así nos gustaría que fuera una
sociedad para las futuras generaciones y
algunos decimos que esta generación está
perdida pero yo he escuchado eso desde
hace mucho tiempo esta generación está
perdida vamos por la que sigue pues
bueno tengamos este compromiso de ir con
la que sigue inculcarle esto a las
futuras generaciones lo necesitamos
lo ideal sería ser capaces de ver que
todos a pesar de estar creciendo como
una sociedad que es una sociedad diversa
que tiene diferentes características ya
les dije que está compuesta por muchas
personas que estas personas les hemos
atribuido un valor a partir de cómo
lucen de cómo son de dónde están si
tienen alguna un padecimiento de salud
pues también es importante reconocer que
independientemente de sus condiciones
pues todas las personas tenemos los
mismos derechos y están reconocidos
universalmente por eso hay tantos
movimientos sociales por eso las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
están a la lucha pie de lucha para que
todo esto se reconozca y es difícil y es
difícil porque nos han inculcado
que la justicia y la venganza es lo
mismo cuando no lo son
y respondemos a veces de forma violenta
pero bueno creo que el gran reto para
las personas que estamos tratando de
hacer una sociedad distinta
y conducirnos bajo una primicia de la
no-violencia y practicar el amor no
siempre en la forma en que nosotros nos
conducimos con las personas es un gran
reto a mí siempre me verán con corazones
esta blusa por cierto viene de una
comunidad maya no hecha con todo el amor
que se requiere siempre me verán con
corazones porque es importante recordar
que todos tenemos emociones que todos
sentimos que todos amamos y que todos
esperamos que nos amen
pues la sociedad es así es como un gran
árbol siempre frondoso no es diverso
cada hoja es distinta están ahí
y luce hermosa y maravillosa cuando está
llena a veces nos enfrentamos con plagas
a veces vienen del incendio como en el
amazonas ahorita desafortunadamente y
eso nos hace repensar no de cómo estamos
haciendo las cosas a veces vienen
movimientos sociales y tumban y sacuden
ese árbol y algunas hojas se caen mueren
se van pero así como los árboles que
vemos cada año que salen estas hojas son
como las generaciones que vienen y
llegan no pero todo pasa a mis estimados
y estimadas amigas todo pasa así como
los árboles las hojas se van cada año
cada otoño caen pero esto es una gran
oportunidad si nosotros reconocemos que
las instituciones no son las que hacen
las cosas sino somos las personas lo que
pasa no es por la institución es porque
alguien tomó una decisión y alguien
también fue cómplice de esa decisión
tomada cuando ésta nos afecta a la
mayoría de las personas
no fue una institución la que permitió
que niños con cáncer tuvieran un
tratamiento de agua con sal no fue una
institución la que permitió que muchos
desvíos de fondos públicos sucedieran
fueron personas una que decidió y en
cantidad que fueron cómplices hasta que
nos conduzcamos con honestidad con
respeto a la humanidad a las personas
podremos lograr algo distinto
afortunadamente habemos unos necios que
vamos tratando de inspirar a las futuras
generaciones y que esperamos que con
mucha determinación
logremos cambios con la creatividad que
siempre nos caracteriza porque no
siempre tenemos los recursos necesarios
que deseamos tener para poder crear
estos cambios pero la creatividad
siempre es una fortaleza es un recurso
que pocos tenemos y cuando la tengan por
favor utilizarla para el bien
la innovación parte de la creatividad no
siempre se refiere a la tecnología sino
hacer las cosas distintas y eso siempre
es un reto pero es una oportunidad
también
y hacerlo con eficiencia en qué sentido
los recursos que tenemos no usarlos de
la forma correcta para poder lograr lo
que estamos deseando lo que estamos
soñando lo que queremos ver en un futuro
de esta sociedad
con compromiso que difíciles o qué
difícil porque a veces nos confundimos y
pensamos que el compromiso tiene que ver
con nosotros mismos y el compromiso es
con todas las personas el compromiso es
con la humanidad el compromiso es con
los que vienen con los niños con los con
los adolescentes con las juventudes con
las personas de la tercera edad y ya se
nos van no pueden tener una vida
y llena de carencias
no podemos permitir que por ser personas
adultas mayores tengan menos
oportunidades o sus derechos sean
violentados el derecho a la salud sobre
todo el derecho una vivienda digna el
derecho a tener alimento tenemos que
pensar en eso si decíamos eso para
nosotros para nosotras tendríamos que
procurar que cuando estemos viejos y
viejas tengamos al menos lo mismo no no
creen no se sueño mucha verdad soy una
romántica lo sé
bueno compasión compasión se logran las
cosas compasión siembra una semilla en
un huerto en una casa hogar compasión
siembra un árbol en una escuela primaria
secundaria preparatoria en una
universidad con pasión trato de inspirar
a las futuras generaciones y bueno esto
es todo una habilidad no que todos
quisiéramos tener pero bueno si no la
tenemos podemos desarrollar la que sea
para poder nosotros lograr los cambios
que deseamos nos hace falta el valor
para hablar para exigir de una forma no
violenta insisto
así se saluda a los mayas los perdón los
nahuas me van a los nahuas que tu
conducta sea intachable para que seas
capaz de ver de frente al sol que
profundo verdad en lugar de un simple
hola
esto es lo que tenemos que ver una
sociedad compleja ese es el reto
aunque dar un paso no nos va a llevar a
nuestro destino no va a ser suficiente
para llegar a nuestro destino
si hay que reconocer que basta una
piedra para hacer que un lago se mueva
un lago con una sola piedra y que basta
un beso para que el corazón lata más
fuerte no hay que tener presente por
favor no lo olvidemos que basta
reconocer lo humano para empezar a
construir sociedades más justas muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]